بعد عشر دقائق على الاقلاع انحرف مسار
الصاروخ الفضائي الاوروبي الجديد فيجا سي
الذي كان يقوم باول رحله تجاريه له وتوقفت
قاعه التحكم في مركز كورب الفضائي في
جويان الفرنسيه عن تلقي البيانات وكان
يفترض بالصاروخ الاوروبي ان يضع قمرين
اصطناعيين من صنع ايرباص لمراقبه الارض
ومسح اي نقطه في العالم مرات عده في اليوم
وفيتا هو الصاروخ الاوروبي الخفيف الجديد
الذي سيستخدم الى جانب صاروخ اريان سته
المستقبلي للسماحي لاوروبا بالمنافسه بشكل
اكبر في سوق الاقمار الاصطناعيه التي تشهد
توسعا كبيرا ويشكر هذا الفشل انتكاسه
كبيره لوكاله الفضاء الاوروبيه المسؤوله
عن برنامج الصواريخ الاوروبيه في حين
تستعمر المنافسه الدوليه في هذا المجال
لاسيا بوجود شركه